bonjour aujourd'hui ça fait neuf ans que
je travaille dans l'informatique
et là vous vous dites c'est quoi le
rapport avec le be for work
je vous rassure je pense piqueurs et
quand je vais vous raconter mon histoire
vous allez comprendre que vous aussi
aujourd'hui vous aurez pu être à ma
place j'ai découvert en fait le concept
d be fair work en décembre 2013
quand une amie suisse m'explique qu'elle
va faire l'aller-retour genève londres
en 24 heures pour aller tester morning
glory ville où l'idée de faire la fête
le matin rendait au travail honnêtement
je me suis dit bon pourquoi pas elle est
revenue elle m'appelle et là elle me
parle de 500 personnes qui dansent qui
sautent qui ceux qui font du yoga qui
sont massés d'ours de licorne
je me dis aime décrit un monde parallèle
parallèle jusqu'au moment où je décide
d'aller voir un d'un petit peu plus près
et là je tombe sur ça
bon jusque là rien de différent un petit
massage pourquoi pas là je vois des gens
déguisés en accorde en effet des gens
qui dansent des gens qu'ils se laissent
aller
des noms des gens qui sont plaisir tout
ça le matin d'aller travailler
mega excentriques c'est vrai et là en
fait j'avais envie de danser ça je me
suis dit ah oui quand même
sans vraiment le lâcher prise ils savent
ce que c'est quand j'ai vu cette vidéo
honnêtement je me suis dit nous pas la
même chose à paris
parce que quand même quand on se voit
demain le matin dans le métro on a un
peu du mal parce que d'être d'accord
avec moi mais la 11e' de parisiens venus
élaborant journal donc là je me suis dit
il faut changer des choses
et donc j'ai même pas attendu de le
tester moi même à londres que j'ai été
happé je leur ai dit bon voilà
j'aimerais avoir la même chose à paris
pourquoi tout simplement parce que à un
moment donné à 30 ans j'avais envie
d'appliquer à moi même ce que gandhi
disait si bien
soyez le changement que vous voulez voir
dans le monde voilà donc voilà j'ai pris
j'ai pris les choses à bras le corps je
me suis lancé dans l'aventuré
j'ai évidemment été aidé par une équipe
exceptionnelle de gens qui avaient la
même envie que moi c'était bouleversé
les codes changer notre façon de vivre
une fois dans deux mois donc des yogis
des masseurs des dj des gens qui m'ont
suivi d'un et c'était pas gagné parce
que bon moi je suis pas nous dire que
c'est pas une clubbeuse et comme vous le
dis dès le départ je suis pas du tout
dans l'événementiel mais bon voilà je me
suis dit pourquoi pas on va essayer de
changer un peu la routine des parisiens
et apporter un peu plaisir de bonheur
a paris une fois dans moi c'est quoi une
chambre donc j'ai été un peu quand même
me renseigner je me suis dit est ce que
vraiment les parisiens vont être
difficiles à lever c'était un peu la
question de me poser eh ben le gros
problème c'est que les études ont
confirmé qu oui bon pour vous ça vaut
peut-être ça vous surprend pas mais moi
comme je suis du matin c'est vrai que
j'ai eu un peu de mal avec ça et j'ai
découvert en effet une étude qui a été
faite pour le mâle pour ikea et qui
s'appelle life atom qui qui décrit en
fait que en effet le matin c'est le
moment le plus stressant de la journée
pour le parisien on a été comparé
évidemment à différentes villes dans le
monde des grandes villes il semblerait
que pour le parisien c'est très
compliqué de se lever parce que dès le
matin il pense à sa journée de travail
le matin c'est le même rituel
on se lève en douche on s'habille
certains prennent leur petit déj ou pas
on écoute la musique sont haletant et
c'est parti et en fait c'est le moment
le pire moment de la journée pour un
parisien parce que le matin il ne fait
rien qu'ils fassent plaisir j'ai pas
comment vous vous êtes le matin mais il
semblerait que le matin les gens se
lèvent
il n'y a aucun moment pour pour lequel 1
il n'y a aucun moment pour la
spiritualité ya aucun moment pour le
temps pour soi on est on line au mail
avant d'aller au boulot on pense à des
choses très santé évidemment après la
journée les stressante
donc quand on voit ça on dit ah bon bah
en fait c'est normal peut-être là la
réaction des gens dans le métro en fait
alors qu'à londres par exemple dans
cette même étude
43% des londoniens donc eux considèrent
que le meut le matin c'est un des
moments les plus importants pour le
développement personnel et la preuve ils
sont quand même plus de 500 à venir se
lever le matin pour faire les morning
lors évident donc maintenant qu'on a dit
ça qu'est ce qu'on fait en charge des
choses donc j'ai créé une association
avec une amie
on s'est entouré des bonnes personnes et
on s'est dit on va se lancer
on s'est dit on va se lancer dans le
premier 8b for work à paris évidemment
on en a on a harcelé le carreau du
temple avec qui on a eu la chance de
commencer
ils ont été visionnaire parce qu'ils
sont dit on voit on va les accompagner
et puis on s'est lancé et on s'est
lancés dont l'idée c'est quand même de
vous montrer un peu ce que ça donne un
before qu'à paris pour que vous
compreniez la différence lorsque je vous
propose c'est de vous emmener dans le
dernier but for work on a pu réaliser en
février dernier voilà l'idée d'un
différent c'est simple on vient on fait
ce qu'on veut
y a pas d'horaire entre 6h30 et 10h30
on est alors que vous voulez vous danser
ou sadou daoudou fait du yoga vous jouez
de masse et vous venez déguisés vous
venez on voulait comme vous voulez vous
pouvez rencontrer les angevins au
passage l'idée c'est vraiment de lâcher
prise
il essaie de ne pas se poser la question
de comment les gens me regardent que
vont dire les gens se fait si si je fais
ça si je viens des guides et ja et à
vraiment c'est un lieu où on est là pour
se faire plaisir
on vient vraiment se faire plaisir on
vient pour rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes on vient pour tester des des
nouvelles choses
on vient pour sauter son envie de sauter
on vient pour dessiner puisque
l'objectif aussi c'est le laisser parler
sa créativité
parce que quand on réfléchit c'est quand
la dernière fois que vous avez dansé
avec vos enfants madame voilà c'est
quand la dernière fois que vous êtes
venus déguisés monsieur et quand l'un
des rares fois où vous avez fait du hula
hoop monsieur bah oui c'est quand on
fait la dernière fois qu'on a laissé
parler sa créativité et quand on s'est
laissé aller en fait là l'idée c'est de
faire une fois par mois est bon mois la
prochaine fois je sais que ce sera le
1er avril pourrait venir à déguiser en
poisson c'est avait envie mais voilà
l'idée d'un be found c'est vraiment ça
c'est vraiment de se lâcher de le faire
en plus avec nos enfants parce que c'est
davantage d'amis falloir c'est quand
même sens et de faire la fête c'est que
ces enfants mais avec ses parents et ses
grands-parents de le faire déguisés ou
pas devenir vraiment pour le plaisir le
plaisir de soi le plaisir
de se faire plaisir en fait c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment l'idée
principale c'est vraiment l'idée
principale
alors maintenant que je vais expliquer
un peu comment ça se passe voulez-vous
dire oui mais est-ce que vraiment ça
marche quoi est ce que c'est vraiment un
truc où les gens se lèvent le matin est
ce que nous parisiens on se lavait pas
jouera sur wii vous parisien alors je ne
sais pas si vous dans la salle vous êtes
levés pour en faire mais sachez que à
londres par exemple ils ont commencé il
était donc en mai 2013 dit et 26 5 mois
plus tard ils étaient 500 à se lever il
continue à semer une fois par mois à
paris on a commencé en juillet 2014
il y avait à peu près 120 personnes
aujourd'hui on a eu un pic jusqu'à plus
de 400 personnes qui sont venues pour
danser pour lâcher prise aujourd'hui le
l'idée et les gens ont bien compris
c'est que une fois par mois c'est rien
une fois par mois pour penser à soi pour
se lever pour se lever est arrivé au
travail est une énergie une énergie
super positive sait rien et en plus les
entreprises ont bien compris parce que
vous à titre individuel vous pouvez vous
dire tiens c'est important pour moi
aussi de le faire de me faire plaisir
mais juste pour la petite histoire il ya
une grande boîte dans l'informatique à
dublin qui a tellement bien compris
qu'aujourd'hui à l'organiser morning
glory ville pour ses employés voilà donc
peut-être que votre entreprise aussi
bientôt près la même chose
quoi qu'il en soit l'idée c'est vraiment
de penser à soi c'est te lâcher c'est de
ne pas penser à ce que vont dire les
autres si vous pensez comme ci ou si
vous pensez comme ça si vous êtes nuls
en yo gabba faites comme moi venez vous
apprendrez mais voilà l'idée s'est
vraiment lâché prix c'est qu'on se fasse
plaisir et il n'y a aucune barrière ont
bien comme on dit
la seule la seule barrière c'est
évidemment la mauvaise humeur à l'entrée
que préférable de laisser voilà
maintenant
moi si j'avais quelque chose à vous dire
c'est que l'idée de buffard works et sur
la base de mon expérience personnelle
c'est de vous dire que moi je les fais
alors je n'étais pas prêt destiné à
organiser ce type d'événement
la seule personne qui peut vous aider à
changer les choses dans votre propre vie
c'est vous la seule personne qui est
acteur du changement c'est vous et ça il
faut vraiment en prendre conscience pour
se dire voilà je me lance gc j'y vais ça
marche ça marche pas bon mais je pense
que à partir du moment où on a pris
conscience que l'acteur du changement
c'est soit pour pour son bien-être
donc par exemple venir un matin faire un
but for work un morning glory ville pour
tester et aller au travail et par la
suite mais aussi dans la vie en général
pour pour changer changer de travail
pour monter un projet voilà s'il ya une
chose à retenir je pense que c'est vous
l'acteur du jugement et vous en être
capable ensuite évidemment toujours sur
la base de cette expérience personnelle
et de cette belle histoire
moi j'ai envie de dire vous monsieur
peut-être que vous avez un projet
personnel vous madame vous avez
peut-être une passion et puis les
étudiants qui sont qui nous reçoivent
aujourd'hui où les jeunes qui ont des
milliers d'idées à la seconde
bah oui devez vous lever vous réveillez
vous essayez d essayer de changer les
choses
n'attendez pas quelqu'un de violent vous
aider je pense que vous avez la
possibilité de réaliser des beaux
projets pro juste savoir se lancer on
dit souvent que l'avenir appartient à
ceux qui se lèvent tôt
moi je dirais l'avenir appartient à ceux
qui se lèvent tôt et surtout à ceux qui
se lancent tôt alors surtout levé vous
et surtout lancez vous